kommt mal ermittelte luca und luca der
hütchen prediger nicht in die höhle
jungs das sind richtige abenteuer
münchen peter nein nein nein
die können da hin der über die erde
wieder raus freuen und herzlich
willkommen zurück seine erfolge
minecraft captain zusammen mit kommen
und ich stehe außerhalb der world bord
ob mein plan für heute ist ein hühnchen
gehege endlich mal aufzustellen weil die
galerie recht überall rum diese scheiß
hühner und ja was dein plan so mein plan
ist es nun bin ich die welt verschönern
wenig chillen eventuell gehen wir heute
noch hoch zum gas mal schauen da wir
wollten ein bisschen am see schild heute
kann ich genau in unserem coolen see
bestehend aus einem wasser so profihaft
jetzt erstmal ein paar zeilen 16 reichen
euch erstmal erhält man eigentlich wenn
man die erde hier umgräbt mit einer
hacke auch daraus sein
ich glaube schon wenn man die erde
umgräbt
hab ich ja ich weiß was du meinst aber
ich glaube nach zusammenbekommt doch
nicht sicher aber wir haben ja auch
überall so grass am rande das ganze auch
noch ab da sind gut ich bei euch dass
hühner gegen ich mache das jetzt einfach
mal hier ich glaube ich hier auch
nochmal in die höhle reisen ich habe das
gefühl wir haben viel zu wenig eisen
macht man nochmals ein tor
was für ein tor absolut applaus zu stäbe
die habe ich stäbe die täten also mal
steht man nicht ob eine tür nehmen als
auch ich weiß ich weiß schon nicht
ständig ja schon wenn mir deine sachen
gibt aber ich hab die stäbe gegeben es
gebe aber ich brauche noch das hier und
dann mache ich nicht mehr in ganz gut es
regnet ja so übel täglich wieder
ja ich habe sehr gut so dann stelle ich
das tor mal hierhin und dann muss ich
jetzt irgendwie diese ganzen münchen da
mal einen losen wenn ich auf die post
dafür hast du samen oder ich hab sagen
okay
guck mal hier die sind alle von der oben
schon da rein gerade ja ich sage jetzt
mal eben hier allein lassen alle
dahergekommen
damit sich alle die da vorne bitte auch
noch 2 volt border dann bekommen wir die
kiste da vor dem wasser echt jetzt
ja das ist ein kleiner see in einer
kiste also ich glaube hühnchen wird echt
unsere hauptnahrung ski komme hat sogar
zusammen eine hand weil die sind nicht
noch mich fokussiert okay an die ecke so
ich da vielleicht einigen kleineren
touren gehen hinter die sind gerade acht
stück mein theoretisches braucht noch
nicht alle hier drin
wir können eigentlich mal ein paar töten
ja da ich mir überlegen aber guck mal
wie viel wir schon drin haben auch das
tor zu tor zusammen aus der hand wieder
raus
so sind doch welche daten welche hier
hier kommen aber alle mittelte luca luka
der hütchen prediger in die höhle jungs
das ist richtige abenteuer münchen alter
besser nein nein nein die können dahin
gerber die erde wieder raus
ich baue selbst werden hast du da
ausländer zäune noch nicht ich hab zwar
erwarte niemand zweimal das mal ganz
kurz schauen mit auch von euch heftig ja
ich mache mal eben auch neue zäune ok
bleibt nun mal kurz da drin und passt
kurz auf einer vom fleck händler für
mich wirklich wie in enger fabrik die
sicher so richtig zudem sowie werden
alle so richtig scheiße gehalten und
alles also gefunden eine höhle reime
wächst da aus dem weg kleine bälle gut
und jetzt alle die noch draußen sind die
wird jetzt einfach nahtlos
abgeschlachtet guckte mir die kuren was
will ich eigentlich
die kugel erst mal hier raus so soll
dieser auch noch tore auf welchen da
hinten ist noch ein schwein es mir
wieder ganze sachen kurz eben wieder zu
werfen
wir liegen hier natur liegen natur
kanadas eine kuh das nur eine kuh zwei
schweine aber nur eine kuh recht jemand
die höhle und gucken ob die kuh da
irgendwo ist sich paar mal gleich die
schweine noch mal können wir ja gar
nicht wir haben ja nur ein denkbares
münchen fleisch hier reiner hast du
schon
ja gut ich gehe mal eben in die höhle
mal gucken ob ich hier unsere cool finde
herr mappus zu ein klein bisschen weise
die kammer aus dem nirgendwo auf diese
ist gegangen ins akh ist wirklich
wirklich gut ist ändern aber der fisch
stinkt ja so hier kommt jetzt auch
irgendwo einsamen neda ist eigentlich
alles voll mit haben schon letzter doch
hier und hast du da sein rausbekommen
leider lebt ich wollte auch mal diese
ganze farm schöner baum nicht schon die
ganze zeit später ein schönes häuschen
bauen
das wird noch so schön hier glaube ich
fällt auf wir sind ja schon die ganze
zeit am wasser wir können uns schon
längst eine lange fahrt machen das jetzt
nicht mal einen plan hat man richtig
schöne farben ja genau und ich ich guck
mal hier der höhle und wenn mal ein paar
rohstoffe ich bin dafür
ich bin bauer aufeinander merke hier ist
alles ausgeleuchtet wir mal die alte
problematik aber trotzdem spanier 1000
monster in diesem projekt ihr kommt noch
allem du kommst noch eine schaufel die
dann das von planern club eine axt
bräuchte ich auch noch ein paar fakten
er brauche ich gar nicht ich nehme jetzt
mal eben hier das wasser weg nein nein
nein nein nein
einige items liegen da noch was alles
mit
ich überlege was ich an wert verloren
haben könnte was denn du bist ganz lange
laufen da kommt einfach mal so ein top
pick mit und fällt runter wieder alles
gibt direkt vor meinen augen auch schon
in comics folgekosten home buttons auf
einmal steht die schweiz vor meinen
augen das war ja so traurig als manchmal
die ganze familie so ein bisschen
schöner was hat dich an wertvollen
sachen aber ich glaube ich hat egal ich
hatte halt mein level die waren halt
wertvoll ja gut darüber kann ich noch
hin wechseln dann mein brustpanzer
vielleicht ich gucke erstmals ich wieder
bekomme brustpanzer immer ärgerlich ich
guck mal einige sachen bekomme ich noch
wieder wie gut mein bogen ist nicht weg
das ist gut mein brustpanzer liegt noch
da okay dass das wichtigste
okay ich bin gleich wieder tot ich bin
gleich müssen wieder lava wird vom
skelett jetzt getötet aber ich hab noch
alles in die truhe retten können ich
stehe mit elf mann sterben kann
soll ich dir helfen unterschiedliches
geht also nicht jeden abend das ist auf
jeden fall hilfe das dann nahm sie so
ich mache mal die ganze sache samen
felder hier kaputt und trifft dabei
einfach nie
so hier noch 1 und da so manche sachen
hat mir einmal richtig hässlich
gestaltet den höhlen abgang ja ist so
dass es so trocken hässlich unser höhen
abgang
das ist echt nicht mehr normal aus
normaler typ denn ich wir sind da wird
nie den höhlen bei uns finden niemals
echt also so traum wird niemals soweit
hierunter finden so mein bogen liebte
macht sehr gut so unendlich wasser haben
wir jetzt noch ein bisschen sand so okay
ich habe alle meine items wieder so und
die fahrt wobei ich denn jetzt war die
farbe hin mal ganz überlegen wollen die
sache gegen regt nicht so oftmals in
reden war ganz viel sekt das ist einfach
so von dumpfer unter thonemann der
aufnahme der will doch keiner hören ich
habe eine spitzhacke verloren in der
lava man dafür eine runde mitleid in den
kommentaren für komme
ich weiß was ich jetzt mache ich baue
man schön abgang in die höhlen in höhe
abschnitt wird das lohnt sich ja das
könnte man so ich mache jetzt meine
wunderschöne farben heute man nicht so
oft schießen es aus sondern mal so ein
bisschen weide macht mal sowas
produktives wer genau und es wird schon
was nicht kaum war es tag wird es schon
wieder nacht hier kommt von alleine
fahren wird richtig schön ich glaube das
schafft sogar noch nicht erfolgen
sollten
das kann alles was reisen ist legt in
den kästen leute können ich kann mir gar
keine eisen spitzhacke mehr machen darf
nur mit steine zu unter nachrichten
kiste liegen zwei also das reichte nicht
für die spitzhacke ja keine ahnung wie
diamanten spitze gut wenn du jetzt die
dallara schwimmst werde ich nicht kommen
wir zum disneyland und jetzt schwimmt da
schon wieder lava
man man man 29 weizenkörner ich es jetzt
sogar fortes fleisch weil du unser
ganzes zimmer auf ist
immer auf dommitzsch ihm nicht nur ein
bisschen kohle da rein so da kommt dann
noch ein bisschen hühnchen rein so da
wieder die ganze kohle rinde haben mama
mama war sogar wieder hessen hin sollte
feucht die home villacher tillich über
diesen endanwender vor mir steht soll da
kommt eine fackel hin und her damit das
ganze auch ausreichend erklärt wird
halte diese fahne der mann so geil
offen scheint einfach auch gut creeper
von allen seiten kommt hierher
vorbeigeflogen
das ist alter der leute von einmal durch
das hühner gegen und kriegt einfach mal
schon wieder fünf eier
ist das krass ich brauch noch sagen hast
du eventuell noch samen nicht bergholz
haben eigentlich auch mittlerweile genug
setzen wir auch überall sein pass fackel
linus hin fackel linus fackel in moskau
hier noch welche mache ich das ganze
immer noch ein bisschen schöner
ich komme ich jedoch klar dass einfach
mal so ein zombie pitman von meiner nase
steht dann so ein pick einfach als dass
peking hat steht einfach vor meiner nase
immer wenn ich irgendwie was zu feiern
oder wenn irgendwas passiert du stirbst
nicht betrunken
hahahahaha echt eine schweinerei hier
memory buffer kannst dann war sein weiß
ich sehe noch vor zwei minuten und chat
niederschlag umgestellt und jetzt fängt
wieder an zu regnen
minecraft hat mit ich glaub auch man so
aber während wundervolles spieler gehege
wir haben eine wundervolle farm noch
zwei world borders ich kann mal ganz
kurz in den erfolgen gucken ja diesen
gas töten daten müssen wir erst noch
machen brauche ein trank das könnte ich
noch machen
dafür muss ich nämlich nur mit den sand
den ich besitze in dicke backen da
verbrenne ich einfach mal ganz kurz
meine wurden du du bist der profi ich
verbrenne die hohe du bist der absolute
profis
auf jeden fall wieso bin ich profi ja
weil du es einfach drauf hast neuestem
vernichtung und so so ein glas wein
trank dann mach mal seinen drei erding
bist du schön tränke machen
ja klar als ob ich bin da der profi hier
tränke machen dann 370 sekunden komme
naja das merke ich schon ein klassetyp
soll den retter in den restlichen land
behalte ich mal eben ganz kurz bis wir
eventuell mal zuckerrohr an pflanzen
möchten so ich hab drei glasflaschen ja
gut ich würde sagen die drei glas
flaschen füllen wir dann in der nächsten
folge bei komme auf dem kanal in dieser
folge geschafft dass wir das ganze ein
bisschen schöner gemacht hab ich weiß
nicht wie das in der höhle und mein gott
aussieht jetzt ein vergleich als branche
hat ich bin gleich um
sie ist mein name nur nach unten gucken
die folge schon wieder eine sehr sehr
lange so die nummer drei das ist aber
echt coole diese mutige her welcher nie
draufgekommen dass wir so was eventuell
machen könnten wir haben alle immer so
ein bisschen ordnung jetzt rein gebracht
hätten das projekt sondern so ein
bisschen mal ein bisschen schöner aber
wissen was schöner gebaut und alles
mögliche gemacht die farm finde ich auch
gut über die fahrbahn so wundervoll oder
gleich da vinci erdschichten oben mehr
wohl hier ist der neue höhleneingang nee
der ist hier nicht mehr sehr schön da
das ist wirklich schön
jacobi fall hammer hammer geil
er war hast du wasser gefunden ja da war
ja so eine wasserfarben da habe ich
alles super gemacht zu haben sei diese
wieder wenn es euch gefallen hat zeigt
mit den bewertungen wir jetzt morgen
wieder bei